what up peeps we got some casting news
revolving the groundbreaking brand new
mcu superhero miss marvel who is getting
her
own series on disney plus so we're gonna
break it all down for you right now on
the ketchup
here we go major things are happening
with the slate of marvel series coming
to disney plus over the next couple of
years so be sure to check out our
episodes on shows like wandavision and
she-hulk for more info because you know
we got your mcu updates and when it
comes to the miss marvel series we now
know that 18 year old canadian actress
iman valani a newcomer appearing in her
first major project will star as kamala
khan aka miss marvel
and i mean talk about a big break after
a couple iterations of miss marvel
over the years kamala khan first
appeared in the comics in 2014
becoming the first muslim and first
pakistani american character to headline
a marvel comic
and now just a few years later marvel is
leaning in pretty heavily on the
character as the studio's first
on-screen muslim hero with her own
series appearances and upcoming mcu
films and making her one of the
centerpieces in the new marvel's
avengers video game
and i just love how she can stretch her
arms out really far in the game
so the story behind miss marvel is that
kamal is just a 16 year old living in
new jersey and a huge
fan of superheroes in fact captain
marvel is her idol but she eventually
becomes one herself after discovering
that she is
in human dna if that sounds familiar to
you perhaps it's because you're thinking
of marvel's very rotten inhumans tv
series which ran for eight episodes on
abc back in 2017. who knows this could
be a way to reintroduce these characters
in a future phase of the mcu or
we'll never see them again
and from those inhuman genes miss
marvel's main superpower is the ability
to shapeshift and she's also a polymorph
meaning she can completely transform her
body by doing things like growing
stretching
and shrinking like i said she's got that
elastigirl stretch thing going on
now when it comes to how she'll actually
fit into the mcu
the pre-covered plan was that the series
would be a part of phase four
coming perhaps in late 2021 or early
2022 but again
as always who knows at this point what
is life but given the characters close
ties with captain marvel
and because brie larson said that she
wants to see it happen
it's a pretty safe bet that miss marvel
will appear in the captain marvel sequel
now slated for july of 2022 that's a yes
or no question
yes story lines are obviously still a
mystery but we do know that in the
marvel's vendors game kamala khan is a
major part of a narrative where she
uncovers a conspiracy that saw the
avengers ostracized
something that could possibly carry over
to the series or in the films
and while we don't know what the story
is we do know who will be creating it
starting with british writer and
comedian bishop ali who will write and
serve as the showrunner
meanwhile the directors who signed on
include the punishers mira menon
two-time oscar winner charming obey
chinoy
and the bad boys for life directing duel
a deal lrb
and bill all follow y'all will never do
that again
alright friends it is time for us to
kick it over to you now how stoked are
you for this miss marvel series
just stretch it out in the comments and
let me know
let us know all your thoughts and
feelings and of course if you want more
movie and streaming news
head on over to rottentomatoes.com but
of course all of our content doesn't
stop there because you should check out
our new
rotten tomatoes is wrong a podcast from
rotten tomatoes because fresh orion is
just the beginning of the conversation
and new episodes drop every thursday and
if you don't want to miss out on any
future episodes of this show because why
would you
be sure to hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and as always
thank you for watching the ketchup my
name is perez or shall i say
miss perez bye
[Music]
you